[Music]
we got a great show tonight we have such
a fantastic lineup of people people that
are okay yeah that's great thank you
very much all right what's your name
there buddy Marc Marc cable there you go
thank you thanks a lot
hi hon what's your name okay I'm sorry
Andy Andy what are you doing oh I'm just
signing some copies of my new memoir you
wrote a new memoir
mr. Richter I've read all 18 of your
memoirs this is the best one yet thanks
Don
wait a minute Andy you can either
straight you've written a teen memoirs
why sure Conan I'll tell you the titles
of all 18 of my memoirs no I didn't ask
to hear the title of all 18 of your
memoirs I never said that I needed to
hear that
okay well first up we've got side-dish
confessions of a top show sidekick
then we've got sidekick to the curb the
Andy rich sidetracked a life less lived
stewing in the shadows the Andy Richter
story oh this is a good one that's me in
the corner good one boss my life as a TV
toady fake laughter real tears beside
pitch tourney hey okay Andy I think we
get the idea
forcing the laughs hiding the gym bottom
pretending to listen the Andy Richter
story dead inside a sidekicks life my
lectern my prison bailing him out the
life and times of an under preesh
underappreciated show savor that title
was a little wordy Andrew and the
terrible horrible no good very bad
career waiting for that guy to shut up
so I can go home the anger at the story
[Applause]
20 feet from dum-dum
oh I wanna punch his face so hard his
murder legal yet just early
and finally my newest memoir okay I
wasn't just curious I asked because I
want to murder someone I work with
[Applause]
you